j'ai failli être en retard et les vrais
parce que je suis venu en début en deux
non pas qu en france on n'a pas de
pétrole mais on a des idées
alors j'ai troqué match fou contre une
double vous l'avez peut-être vu devant
le studio c'est une deux boeufs blanc
tâché de roue alors quand on dit qu'est
ce que vous avez comme voitures jugées
une 9e alors les gens sont surpris parce
qu'ils s'attendent à le voir il enrôle
sauce l'artiste
alors quand ils voient arriver en 2 me
ils sont déçus alors les réflexions des
gens tiens là la paire de voeux du père
de l'eau ça fait mal sur mon passage les
quolibets les mamans à leurs petits
enfants
si les deux équipages cacher vos rouge
tablier
alors les enfants sauf qu'ils veulent
parce qu'ils te veux ça pose des
problèmes
exemple un feu rouge une tâche aux
s'arrête pas le 2 et pas forcément le
roux ça les excite alary force et quand
ces verts eeb rod alors vos faire-part
dieu de me qui écoute ça fait peur
cet après midi sur mon passage est un
irresponsable qui a crié suivent elles
peuvent appeler un tas tension celui
avec des pancartes oui marc moreau rage
pour corser le tout il y avait une
affiche de la vache qui rit
on ne sait pas ce qui se passe dans la
tête des bleus est-ce qu'ils ont cru que
la vache foot et 2 ils ont foncé dans le
panneau tête baissée et pour retirer ne
veut pas ce qu'un bug c'est comme un
bulldozer ça enfonce tout est encore un
bulldozer vous pouvez l'arrêter
vous n'avez qu'à couper l'arrivée
d'essence ya qu'à couper mets un boeuf
qu'est ce que voulait couper est lui
déjà
il faut bien rire un peu il faut bien
rire un rire un peu passé à propos du
rire il faut tout même je vous le dise
parce que c'est important
à propos parce que le rire comme chacun
sait ou ne sais pas le rire c'est une
énergie contenue qui y'a pas de quoi
rire c'est une énergie contenue qui se
libèrent rapidement bon et en se
libérant elle fait vibrer les muscles et
plus vulnérables les plus fragiles qui
se trouvent être des zygomatiques très
exactement bravo monsieur
elle a supposé que les muscles fessiers
et bénéficie troy n'a pas l'effectif
soit plus vulnérables que les
zygomatiques
eh bien on rirait comme ça on l'a fait
vous voyez une salle cuiry désopilant je
pouffe
un risque mais ça ferait oui enfin rit
aux éclats je vois pas très bien quoi
jacques ory
on l'a échappé belle
attention nos ancêtres y est comme ça
aux ancêtres et primitif guerrier comme
l'homme des cavernes le rire caverneux
non
et les primitifs les primitifs il rit je
n'ai rien contre les primitifs je n'ai
rien contre les primitifs qu'ils ont
tout inventé
ils ont tout tenté
la pierre taillée qui est ce qu'il a
inventé la pierre taillée imprimerie qui
le feu qui a vanté fins politiques
c'est une technique de 110 villages
alors un jour il a pris de pierres une
dans chaque main aux innocents les mains
pleines vous allez affronter comme ça
tout s'est fait des étincelles
alors le chef un primitif aussi le chef
primitif mais chef
tout d'abord il avec du feu c'est à dire
qu'elle a vu de la fumée mais comme il
ya pas de fumée sans feu mais à dire
aller chercher le sorcier pour chercher
car yeux un chakri primitif
il ya eu des primitifs à l'époque et les
publie cet indice est innocent il a dit
à l'innocent et refait refait devant le
sorcier ce que tu nous as fait alors les
nôtres avec ses deux petites pierres
d'hier fait petite flambée gerland le
sorcier a dit feu de dieu
ça sent le roussi
il a joué avec les amulettes il faut le
brûler alors le chef indien coi et
l'autre innocent il a dit ça il a vu le
feu au bûcher qu'on venait de dresser
pour lui alors autour du bus les
primitifs
il s'appelle derrière par terre alors la
réflexion qu'il espère enfin
heureusement qu'il n'a pas inventé la
poudre
parce qu'en prix de lebron il aurait
fallu le faire et il reste à peine
derrière plus fort que les autres
ça lui a durci les fessiers le les
fessiers sans lui - je lui ai rappelé
que les zygomatiques
le rire lui est monté à la gorge et il a
fait il avait inventé le rire
[Applaudissements]
premier type les primitifs en tout cas
montée de la roue la roue la roue les
fruits le fusain c'est tout de même un
primitif qui le premier a décidé sur la
paroi de la caverne bison futé avec des
flèches ou la vache qui rit tout inventé
des prix plutôt et moi moi moi qui suis
évolué 6 quai je l'inventé
voici tout de même pas ce que tu tout
même l'histoire telle que je viens de
vous la conter
c'est moi qui on ne rit plus on ne rit
plus comme avant écoutez en venant ici
j'ai vu dans la rue j'ai vu ce soir un
type tu veux un type soirée ça ne m'a
pas fait rire
j'écoutais avant quand je voyais choir
un type jeunesse café et là c'est tout
juste si je suis pour les vidéos est ce
que vous vous êtes fait mal
faut dire qu'elle a eu du mal sur ce que
maintenant les gens savent plus ce soir
quand tu joues un exploit triste chance
à pleuvoir et safavora wilb bonsoir il
s'en prend soir ils s'imaginent que ce
soir c'est d'histoire soir n'est pas
déchoir un homme qui a chuté pas déçu à
condition qu'ils soient bien comme un
aimant paix ou que tu feras choix bien
ce que mon père isaac hicham il savait
ce que c'était que ce soir il avait été
auguste deux soirs de soirée dans un
cloud
un chapiteau il avait pendant l'accident
la chute dans la sciure et il aurait
voulu que je sois mieux que lui
artouste imz échoir comme ça note de ses
genoux il passe il ya des choix à faire
nous sommes dans l'institution qu'est ce
qu'il a une carte noire
non seulement il faisait chaud car chez
moi mais il m'en voyez soir chez les
autres et en a c'est pas parce qu'on a
mal fait les autres non je vois mieux
chez soi mais parce qu'on soit sans
retenue on jouera pour soi on est chez
les hauts d'avant le choix font mettre
des gants permettez que je sois ici boom
ou bien préférer vont je sois labeaume
mal alors quand on a toujours vu dans la
chute dans la sueur et que soudainement
il faut soir sur le tapis
franchois pas dans son élément on soit
plus haut que son haut rang alors
réflexion où il manque de savoir choix
vous avez vu comme moi je suis ma chère
oui parce que dans un certain milieu
[Musique]
parce que dans un certain milieu voir ça
s'apprend et les cours du soir
[Applaudissements]
j'y suis allé vous apprennent à choir en
trois soirs alors vous avez le pressoir
à dire ces instants qui précèdent le bon
choix
bon alors vous avez le choix romandie
alors là en soit on peut pas le choix
bon et une fois je suis vous avez la
prévoir
moi j'ai eu des après soir difficile
parce que oui même plus m'asseoir
alors comment au bout de trois choix
enchaîné toujours pas fichu de bien
choisir les sujets légers c'est tombé
sur mon père en sortant mon père me dit
mondial échoue un peu devant moi que je
vois où tourner sur le plan choir bon
enfin j'étais pas chaud pour que je me
le choix c'est pas que tu sois mal mais
touche warhead et 10 fois sous deux fois
soit comme le char les regards d'un
chaque fois les choix comme lui il
touche voire bien parce qu'un chat un
chat un chat ses choix je suis anti
comme un chien aussi ses formes est
moins bien qu'un chat à qui un jour j'ai
vu un chat choix sur un chien chien je
me fous un petit chouchou qui co après
une poule qui faisait croire d'un
perchoir
ensuite tout un concours de
circonstances fait reprendre c'est à
dire que la poule avait vu choir un
mouchoir d'un séchoir à forte chute en
fin de l été chercher vers le chu
revoyons la poule soir c'était lent chez
achats prochain poursuite alors attendez
plus jouer la chute est alors le chu h
une flash mob l'alleud le chat sur le
chiot ses ennemis et bien bel et bien le
chouchou a moins bien je suis sûr que le
cha cha chichis
[Applaudissements]
je vous fais une petite sonnerie
l'attaquent la taxe serait pas que je
sonne la taxe de france à mon grand père
parce que mon grand-père a rendu son
dernier souffle l'obscur sur le champ de
bataille
ces groupes et ils sont l attaque est
l'ennemi attaque etc
alors il a pris un boulet dans le
pavillon il a avalé l'embouchure ça
pardonne pas alors quand on a rapporté
son clairon à sa veuve elle a dit oui
quelle idée aussi d'aller faire de la
musique dans un moment pareil on ne se
rendait pas compte
alors mon père a repris le flambeau mais
flambeau parce que nous sommes tous
clairon de père en fils et mon père a
fait toutes les guerres en tant que les
rangs d'ailleurs pour mon père la guerre
c'était une belle sonnerie il les a tout
fait
il a sonné toutes ces attaques de la
guerre 14-18 et toutes les retraites
dans la guerre 39 40
et les morts à la retraite d'une attaque
dans son billet le destin il faut près
se tromper de sonneries parce que la
sonnerie et sonneries bon exemple ouvrit
le mans fermez le ban c'est la même
chose alors le soldat qui n'a pas obtenu
qu on ouvrait le banc quand on ferme y
croient qu'on louvre et il a tant
qu'ancien alors quand on ouvre un
nouveau dû croire que c'est la fermeture
et rend le fait lui pas c'est comme ça
qu'on perd les guerres titre d'ailleurs
le clairon pardonnez moi l'expression
ils sont tous un peu sonné voir mon
voisin c'est mon professeur de crayon en
plus déjà pendant la guerre il était
porte drapeau il a tellement pris
l'habitude de brandir un drapeau que
depuis que la tête drapeau il brandit
plus il est inutile comme parce que l'on
qui m'ont déplu il émettait alors
quelques fois j'entends sa femme qui est
une grille qui lui écrivait brandi autre
chose
non c'est un rapport rien elle écrit
accroche un drap blanc ou d'un manche à
balai et bondouy capituler
puis l'entente parce qu'ils jouent ils
apprennent oreilles alors quand il quand
ils donnent une leçon quand ils jouent
ça donne ça
[Musique]
qui voulez-vous me prêter une oreille
attentive parce qu'il paraît quand on
prête l'oreille on entend mieux c'est le
font c'est faux
il m'est arrivé de prêter l'oreille d'un
sourd il entendait pas mieux parce que
vous avez les phrases toutes faites
comme ça allait frappe j'ai ouï dire
qu'ils avaient des choses qui est entré
par une oreille et ressorti par l'eau
non mais franchement je n'ai jamais rien
vu entré par une oreille et encore moins
à en sortir il ya qu'en littérature
course a évidemment de rabelais de
rabelais nous lisons que gargamel à 1000
gargantua au monde par leur et gauche
parce qu'il sous-entend que par leur
aile droite il va se passer des choses
dites dans des grilles et des sucettes
pas de quoi vous faire dresser l'oreille
alors le verrou ir au présent ça fait
jour jours ci au lieu de dire j'entends
jeudi joie
les gens vont penser que ce que
j'entends il aurait eu alors que ce que
j'entends peut être particulièrement
triste
il faudrait préciser n'est ce pas dieu
que ce que joie et triste
[Rires]
joie du mois tu vois mon chien qui aboie
le soir au fond des bois jolis ils
jouent assez bête loi mois el ouali ce
que nous allions l'eau al watan
sérieux de dire l'oreille on dit louis
louis de loi oui pour peu que l'on
appartienne à louis alors la louisiane
oui ah oui ah oui et karoui louis de loi
de louis alaoui ce que tous trois mois
et quoi toutefois et bientôt doit avoir
quand mon chien aboie le soir au fond
des bois toutefois voir wouah qu'elles
ont passées ça fait jouit joue il n'y a
vraiment pas de quoi beaucoup de mime
mes camarades si j'en ai fait beaucoup
depuis six saisons qui ont un talent fou
c'est vrai et puis j'adore sont des gens
qui sont qui n'hésite pas à s'oublier
pour être un autre et c'est ce que je
voudrais vous dire c'est que quelques
fours dit qu'un artiste sait tout faire
tu sais tout faire aujourd'hui on sait
tout faire
anonyme c'est tout faire mais un mille
ne peut pas tout faire
un jour je devais me met quelqu'un qui
n'a rien à faire
et vrai j'ai rien pu faire parce que ne
rien faire
ça peut se dire mais ça ne peut pas se
faire et depuis je pouvais pas dire je
ne pouvais pas le faire parce que le
personnage qu'il n'avait rien à faire
non plus n'avait rien à dire
et le directeur avait bien spécifié il
m'avait surtout pensez bien ce que vous
avez à faire c'est à dire en fait penser
à rien il avait ajouté surtout ne le dit
pas et je lui avais donné ma parole de
mines que je ne dirai rien
[Rires]
alors je suis entré sur scène comme ça
j'ai commencé à ne rien faire sans rien
dire ça à l'air de rien mais faut le
faire il suffit pas de le dire
et paradoxalement plus je ne faisais
rien plus les gens disaient qu'est ce
qui fait le public n'est pas fou il
voyait bien que faisait quelque chose
mais comme c'était rien ils se
demandaient ce que j'étais venu faire et
les critiques dans la salle voyez bien
que je ne faisais rien et que je le
faisais bien et s'attendait à plus et
moi qui déjà ne faisait rien je pouvais
pas faire moins
les embrassades qui voyait rien ils ont
commencé à trouver à redire donc au
moins faire un geste
avoir un bon mouvement pour ce que
voyant moi j'ai fait le seul geste
qu'approuvent espère mettre quelqu'un
qui n'a rien à faire sans qu'on dise il
en fait trop j'ai fait un geste
d'impuissance
alors les gens dans la salle qu'est ce
qui dit alors là j'ai rompu le silence
j'ai dû mesdames et messieurs mais je
n'ai rien dit qu'est ce que j'avais dit
là le directeur rideau non seulement je
paye un mime à ne rien faire il ne le
fait pas mais en plus il ne tient pas sa
parole il parle il a dit monsieur vous
n'êtes même pas bons à rien alors le
lendemain dans la presse quand android
quand on dit les critiques comme j'avais
rien fait ils n'ont rien dit mais en
bien
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est quelquefois on dit il ya des
choses qu'il ya des choses qu'on
n'explique pas les choses inexplicables
les choses dont on n'ose pas parler
tellement elles sont étranges
il ya quelques jours je le redis t il ya
quelques jours jean tracy je rentrais
chez moi et leur pouvait-il être 2
heures du matin il y avait un brouillard
un brouillard à couper au couteau et un
trou d'un coup j'entends fils d'abraham
fils d'abraham comme j'étais tout seul
je dis oui
chic et plus j'entends une voix
lointaine je suis jéhovah combien de
témoins
[Applaudissements]
je vous écoute la voix me dit tu es bien
le fils d'abraham
j'ai entre autres je ne suis pas le seul
ben nous sommes tout un peuple avec le
fils d'abraham et la voix me dis
justement c'est un appel au peuple que
je viens de 15 mg pourquoi moi aider
parce qu'on a trouvé personne d'autre
bon voilà je voudrais te mettre à
l'épreuve comme j'ai mis jadis ton père
à l'épreuve si le père de hausse et non
le père abraham à j'ai dit c'est cette
histoire ancienne et piwi temps
souvient-il j'avais premier abraham une
descendance innombrables des fils des
petits fils des arrières petits fils
tout un peuple
à condition qu'ils me sacré vient son
fils si je sais il l'a pas fait vilon
parce qu'au dernier moment
mam un refus son bras je dis vous avez
eu là un beau geste
ça je ne serais pas là alors je me dis
voilà je voudrais tout soumettre la même
épreuve sacrifie moi ton fils si vous
trouviez malgé parent d'enfant à une vie
c'est parce qu'on m'avait dit enfin bon
enfin
edit ça fait rien sacrifier moi ta femme
jenny là d'accord j'ai forgé en parle un
petit louis bien que c'est pour la bonne
cause c'est d'y être vous sûr que ce
soit la bonne
parce que déjà que je l'épousé pour le
bon motif alors ce n'était pas le bon on
est de toute façon au dernier moment
ma main retiendra-t-on bras j'ai dû vous
pouvez me signer un papier dit ce qui
est écrit est écrit alors j'en ai parlé
à ma femme elle a très mal pris
ouais couteau sous la gorge
déjà que je puisse sacrifier pour toi si
en plus faux que le couple enquête pour
sa famille jeudi enfin comment tu
conduis une sacrée promotion ou un fils
de famille devenir le père du peuple
elle a compris l a compris c'est elle
même qui arment et mon bras elle m'a dit
vas-y vas-y
elle m'a dit tu es sûr que tu es
derrière toi je sens son souffle alors
pourquoi ici tu fais parce que je ne
suis pas sûr que sa main soit assez
forte pour retenir membres
on a pas on se rend pas compte mais on
commet des petits forfaits qui sont
quand même qu'ils sont assez à ces
affreux films écouter l'histoire
je suis entré dans une auberge pour y
dîner alors sur la carte qui avait
marqué poussins rôti j'ai commandé un
poussin rôti et j'ai eu un petit poucet
jamais opté pour faire c'est mignon à
croquer ce qui bouge jaune comme ça ça
fait qu il était pas puis
il est mangé dans l'ombre au bon ça va
être dur à cuire
elle a vécu elle a fait son temps mais
un petit poucet en détient donc sorti
vainqueur savait lui-même sur cuir neuf
ça vaut guère mieux parce que à chaque
fois qu'on va se faire cuire un oeuf
c'est comme si on envoyait un peut
s'inscrire cuirs gras et qu'est ce qui
fait de poussins c'est là on est prêt si
on est prêt mais n'oublie pas sûr parce
qu'il ya quand même ce dilemme se dit
même que chacun connaît qu'est-ce qui
fait l'oeuf
c'est la poule et qu'est-ce qui fait la
pole
c'est alors la question est qui a
commencé
heslov le père de la poule où la poule
la maire de laives ça peut pas être le
coq les coqs ne pompe pas deux quoi
qu'ils aient pas de poule sans eux sans
enjeu les coques quand ya pas de coke
sans elle sans elle les poules
bah oui alors oui abbas en elle elle va
sans elle y aurait pu ni coop des
pouilly poussins et je souhaite au mieux
parce que j'aurais mangé autres champs
et bien j'aurais mangé du vos vieux
peuvent encore bon il a vécu un petit
mot j'avais déjà vu une petite tête de
veau
à la vinaigrette j'aurais mieux fait de
manger un oeuf parce que comme on dit
qui mangent à 920 bof ce qu'on m'a
demandé de faire un discours
je vous signale tout de suite mesdames
et messieurs que je vais parler pour ne
rien dire
je sais vous pensez s'il n'a rien à dire
ils feraient mieux de se taire j'aime
c'est trop facile
c'est trop facile vous voudriez que je
fasse comme tous ceux qui n'ont rien à
dire et qu'ils gardent pour eux et bien
non mesdames et messieurs moi quand je
n'ai rien à dire je veux compte je veux
en faire profiter les autres et si
vous-même mesdames et messieurs vous
n'avez rien à dire eh bien on en parle
on en discute je suis pas ennemi du
colloque mais me direz-vous si nous
parlons pour ne rien dire de quoi allons
nous parler d'un de rien de rien car
rien j'ai paris à la preuve assez
complet le soustraire rien - rien
n'égale moins que rien alors si on peut
trouver moins que rien c'est que rien
vous déjà quelque chose on peut acheter
quelque chose avec rien en multipliant
bon une fois rien c'est rien deux fois
rien c'est pas beaucoup
d'accord mais trois fois rien pour trois
fois rien on peut déjà acheter quelque
chose
pour pas cher bon maintenant si vous
multipliez trois fois rien par trois
fois rien rien x rien galles rien 3 x 3
égale neuf ça fait rien de neuf à l'est
alors chose parlons de son talon parlons
de la situation ce n'est pas la
situation sans préciser laquelle si vous
le permettez je faire brièvement
l'historique de la situation quelle
qu'elle soit et quelques mois souvenez
vous la situation pour n'être pas pire
que celle d'aujourd'hui n'en n'était pas
meilleur non plus déjà nous allions vers
la catastrophe et nous le savions nous
en étions conscients car il faudrait pas
croire que le responsable d'hier était
plus ignorant de la situation que le
sont ceux d'aujourd'hui
d'ailleurs ce sont les mêmes oui la
catastrophe nous le pensions étaient
portes demain c'est à dire qu'en fait
elle devrait être pour aujourd'hui
d'ailleurs si mes calculs sont justes
or que voyons nous aujourd'hui qu'elle
est toujours pour demain
alors je vous pose la question mesdames
et messieurs s en remettant toujours au
lendemain la catastrophe que nous
pourrions faire le jour même que nous
éviterons
signal entre parenthèses que si le
gouvernement actuel est pas capable
d'assumer la catastrophe
il est possible que l'opposition sont
nos pères
[Applaudissements]
l'imi me surveille dans la neige jusque
là
le blizzard blizzard blizzard moi j'ai
dit bizarre vous avez dit bizarre
tiens comme c'est bizarre j'arrive de
loin là pour dan igloo le tout à l'igloo
je frappe à la porte de l'igloo
vous avez déjà frappé la porte de
l'igloo ouvre quand la neige est molle
vous allez braves qui passe au travers
yann eskimos un primitif
quand il voit dépasser une maille entrée
j'entre atmosphère glaciale où puis-je
m'asseoir sur la banquise will paul pour
les 1000 à victor c'est ça de la part de
la part de blizzard
bizarre bizarre moi je dis bijaoui
partir comme c'est bizarre incident a
été éteinte
vous avez du feu alors le primitif avec
un glaçon dans chaque main jim singh jeu
ça ne prend pas effectivement ça n'a pas
pris
heureusement que j'aime et un nul est
alors l'autre primitif et enyeama tiaret
vous allez faire fondre la maison au
vous avez fait un trou dans la moquette
[Musique]